- [Instructor] Here is a passage
from the Scottish philosopher, writer,
even a little bit of mathematics,
historian Thomas Carlyle.
And, he wrote this On
Heroes, Hero-Worship,
& the Heroic in History.
And this is in reference to his view
on Mohammed and the spread of Islam.
A poor shepherd people,
he's referring to the
Arabs before Mohammed,
roaming unnoticed in its deserts
since the creation of the world:
a Hero-Prophet was sent down to them
with a word they could believe;
see the unnoticed becomes
the world-notable,
the small has grown world-great;
within one century afterwards,
Arabia is at Grenada on
this hand, at Delhi on that.
He's speaking of within 100
years of Mohammed's death,
the Muslim empire has spread
from what would eventually
be Southern Spain, all
the was to Northern India.
These Arabs, the man Mahomet,
and that one century,
is it not as if a spark
had fallen, one spark,
on a world of what seemed
black unnoticeable sand;
but lo, the sand proves explosive powder,
blazes heaven high from Delhi to Grenada.
I said, the Great Man was always
as lightning out of Heaven;
the rest of men waited for him like fuel,
and then they too would flame.
And Thomas Carlyle is known
as one of the proponents
of the of Great Man view of history,
that history is nothing but the story
of a series of great men,
who changed the direction
in which humanity travels.
So, what we're gonna do in this video
is think about whether it
really is all about a great man,
or were there other things
that were in the context
of the time and space in
which these things occur.
This is what the world
looked like in the year 600.
Mohammed starts spreading
his revelations in 610,
and so you can see on this
map, there's two major powers:
the Byzantine, which is
the Eastern Roman Empire,
the vestiges of the Roman Empire,
and you also have the
Sassanid Persian Empire.
The Byzantines are a Christian empire,
and the Sassanids are Zoroastrian,
and Mohammed is from the Quraysh tribe,
which is in charge of Mecca,
which is considered a pilgrimage site
for the various tribes of Arabia.
But, you can see that
Arabia is fragmented,
and this doesn't even do justice
to how fragmented it was.
But, if you fast forward 200
years, you see a major change,
and in fact, you wouldn't
have to go all the way to 800,
even by the early eighth century,
you see that Islam has spread
from the Iberian peninsula
all the way to the Indus,
and most of this, as mentioned,
happens within 100 years
after Mohammed's death.
But, let's ask our central question:
why did Islam emerge so
rapidly where and when it did?
And there's no clear right
or wrong answer here,
it's all going to be conjecture,
but that's what's fun about history,
we can think about what we think we know,
and then we can debate,
and think about are there
some patterns here that we
see over and over in history?
Well, what's the context?
So, we know for a fact
that Arabia was fragmented,
that the law of the land
in Arabia was tribal,
and tribal justice, and this is the world
that Mohammed grew up in.
The various tribes often
worshiping different gods.
We also know at this time that Mohammed
had exposure to other religions,
some of which had penetrated
the various tribes of Arabia.
Most notably, you have Christianity,
and Mohammed's wife's cousin
was, in fact, a Christian.
And you also have Judaism.
These two clearly being related religions,
Christianity coming out
of a Jewish tradition.
We also know that the
two great empires here,
the Byzantines and Persian empires
are in constant conflict, and in fact,
the Arabs and many in the Middle East
are the pawns in that conflict.
And so, you have the
Byzantines versus the Persians,
with the possibility of
those living in their lands
might not have been happy with either.
There's also the sense that
we're at the very beginning
of a long decline for
the Byzantine Empire.
So, one thesis could be that
Mohammed was able to bring
many of the ideas of
Christianity and Judaism,
but these ideas helped to
unify a fragmented Arab people.
And not only did it unify them,
but it gave them the energy
that you could have
through religious zeal,
and that energy is what allowed them
not only to unify in Arabia,
and they're able to unify most of Arabia
by the time of Mohammed's death.
But, within 100 years of his death,
they're able to take over
the entire Sassanid Empire
and make major inroads
into the Byzantine Empire.
And so, one argument might be,
and I encourage you to argue with me,
that they were unified, they
had this missionary zeal,
which perhaps was only seen
in Christianity before Islam,
and they were able to
take advantage of conflict
and discontent between the Byzantines
and Persians in order to spread.
Now, another question is do
we see any patterns here?
Are there any other examples
in history of this happening?
Well, the most comparable
religion is Christianity,
which is, today, larger than Islam,
but Christianity, you have
a long period between Jesus,
who is the central figure of Christianity,
who is the underlying spiritual figure,
and when Christianity really spreads,
and really becomes and empire,
and that really starts with Constantine,
roughly 300 years after the time of Jesus.
What's interesting about
the example in this video,
the example of Islam, in
terms of the religion,
Mohammed plays a little
bit of both of these roles.
He is a spiritual figure,
he has revelations,
but he is also the founder of an empire,
he also governs, he is also a
military and political figure.
And so, perhaps for the first
time in history on this scale,
you have the combination
of religious zeal,
of spiritual belief, of faith,
combined with governance,
combined with the desire
to create an empire.
In terms of empire, the only
thing that might be comparable
in terms of the vastness and
the speed in which it happens,
is the Mongol empire, the
Mongols are an example
of people who were
fragmented initially, tribal,
unified by Genghis Khan,
and through that unification
were able to spread incredibly rapidly,
and take on some long historic
and possibly declining empires.
So, I'll leave you there,
it's a fascinating question
that historians debate to this day.
Islam started awfully fast,
and spread awfully fast.
Why did this happen?
Was it some unique
characteristics of Mohammed?
characteristics of the religion?
Or, as Thomas Carlyle alludes to,
maybe this whole region was just waiting
for something like this,
something to unify the tribes of Arabia
and take on the decaying
Byzantine and Sassanid empires.